I'm very happy of being here today's an
honor to speak as a strange loop the
title of my talk is from video games to
fashions a machine learning yearning and
to be honest it has been one of the most
difficult talks for me to prepare and
this is due to my current or this summer
professional circumstances let me start
summarizing my very briefly my my
experience to focus on the last stage -
that is going to be the focus of my talk
so I start back in 2005 working on the
Large Hadron Collider the particle
physics accelerator in Geneva working
theoretical division solving complex
mathematical problems when I was there I
wanted to to apply my mathematical
background to solve real-world problems
so it was then when a colleague of mine
told me dude I mean there is a company
that is doing forecasting position
forecasting to solve some problems so I
joined this is when I started and this
is what I've been doing my whole career
solving practically sequential analysis
forecasting problems so it was in 2010
that I moved to Germany to work in
recurring no one nervous before all the
deep learning thing started and also
when people start talking about actual
big datasets I joined the German Weather
Service to work in numerical weather
prediction so I wanted to work with
really big datasets so I start work with
satellite data so and this was this
experience for me had a very strong
influence for the rest of my career
because there I learned how to really
put science into production so numerical
weather prediction systems are probably
the most robust prediction system that
we humans we have made since everything
started after the Second World War and
planes fly because of this operational
prediction system so the problems I was
solving there it was
the as probably you know atmosphere
dynamics is very highly Karthik's of the
differential equations that govern the
sky are very sensitive to the initial
conditions so the best initial
conditions are coming from the satellite
but the satellite data are huge so it's
impossible to integrate those
information into the numerical weather
systems so my problem was precisely so
of that I mean select the right amount
of data quick to be able to put this
information as for the numerical weather
system so while I learned earth is like
okay we have this super cool very robust
prediction system operationally why this
is not done in every industry that has a
decent amount of data to have this this
system I mean working to support any
decision at all levels of the of the
industry so this was 2014 I moved to
Japan to work again with satellite data
mawari nine one satellite at Japanese
launch to the sky and it was then when I
decided to change and apply it I mean
what I learned in the operational
prediction systems for other industries
and I found the Jacana data yokozuna
data is some machine learning company an
operational machine learning platform
that we built to predict individual
player behavior so the last four years
I've been working on this and and when I
applied for my talk had the strength up
I was still the CEO of this company so
or you know the I mean the whole focus
was going to talk about this but life is
complicated and this summer I changed my
career and I joined indie text that
turns out to be the largest fashion
retailing organization maybe you know
one of the most famous brands is Zara
so now I work for a profession so it was
complicated for me to select the subject
but at the end there are many
any challenges and common places that
both industry have and this is what I'm
going to talk today so video game data
the sorry
the data the player generator among the
one of the best data to describe human
behavior so when I play your place again
we express very nuanced motivations
emotions started you thinking even
addictions so player data become perfect
playground to understand play I mean
human behavior so this is one of the
initial motivations to start working
with those data sets and also because
traditionally they were not properly
using the data for to understand player
needs and to develop the games to decide
the games so which kind of operational
platform we built in the last four years
so we we were predicting when a player
is going to leave play about player so
since you joined the game after three
days we know until winter stage you're
going to get which kind of contest
you're going to like and which kind of
risky are you able to take so this one
information that most of the game
studios were not having so this will be
provided in an operational manner so
also connecting to the game an i10
recommendation system etc that's because
I know that some people I mean some some
people in the audience are working on
this field I mean we we have plenty of
papers and many papers publish on this
field so if anyone is interested I mean
we can talk later
so and well fashion industry so it's one
of a part of being one of the biggest
industries in the world with a strong
economical and social impact world wild
is a way I mean it goes with your basic
needs it's a way to define our
personality our individuality was very
interesting for me what I watched one
video of one of the other scientists
from Cambridge analytic that one of the
most significant variables
to predict the political preference were
in fashion and music so so fashion
industrials relied a lot on human
creativity to be student successful so
they also similar to video games whereas
lower to realize the potential of
machine learning applications to include
you know in other operations so but
because of the huge amount and the rich
data that they generate I believe that
this is going to change and it's going
to be transformational for this industry
so in I want to introduce in the text
because I think it's an ideal example to
to the challenge that the whole industry
is facing so Indy Texas organization
that I mean cover the whole cycle since
product design production distribution
and sales of the items I mean both in of
line shops and also e-commerce so we
have plenty of challenges I mean ranging
from customer understanding from very
complex supply chains and focusing on
sustainability so able to produce and to
much every supply and demand every piece
of on Sol clothes it's a it's an error
it's a failure of the of the matching
between supply and demand also we very
interesting problem and interesting data
sets we have what it's called RF ID so
we have a full track of every product
every item
since these produce entities salt so we
can understand all dynamics of the shops
and all the full track and behavior of
of dynamics of the of the of the
products
so what does those industry have in
common so that that success right now I
mean relies on careful balance in art
and science so probably I mean the word
art is what they they have in common
I've been working with game designers
for for four years and probably the
biggest challenges and I find in my job
is that I work with humans and humans
has this issue that it was it was sound
I mean by the work of Amos burski and
Daniel Kahneman about behavioral
economics that we are very bad making
estimations we are terrible doing
predictions and worse than that we
believe that we are great so I love this
sentence - a deterministic device thrown
into a realistic universe so we we think
in a deterministic way and yeah what
every decision must be privada sztyc so
this these are actual notes from amos
some people produce very little and
explain everything so we are able to
explain whatever with any random
thinking this one I mean happens very
often to me people often work hard to
obtain information they already have and
about new knowledge when I saw something
that that they know yeah it's great you
are right when I find when they date out
the models say something that is
extremely volatile because it's
something that never seen even with the
same level of accuracy of the previous
statement so we're pros result now this
is wrong everything that has already
happened must have been inevitable well
this is one maybe was possible to avoid
it
so these one of the biggest challenges
talking about precise challenges I just
pick up two of them from every every
field so inventory management as I said
fashion products has a very short life
cycle with highly volatile the monitor
changing so the matching is is really
complex and I'm really looking forward
to to work on this and even optimization
it is for videogames so for see the how
players are going to react to the
different content of the video game is
it's crucial to understand I mean and to
generate new content so particularly in
game events so optimize when is the
right time to publish a particular event
is crucial and to to be able to manage
the game properly and be successful in
it so probability forecasting is it's a
method that can help on both both
challenges so the estimated probability
distribution of a time series future
given his path is going to be of
obviously key and assisting it's still a
very I mean open challenge do it
properly and be able to be in production
in operational manner and yeah be able
to to generate content
I mean accordingly based off of the
spirits of the players and not only not
only be biased to one certain group of
players to be able to generalize and
even go for a in the direction of
personalized games so basically what
what is needed to mean in both sides
maybe it's more evident for supply chain
and retaining problems but also for
video games we need the right product at
the right location at the right time
with the right price but not only for
for physical items also for beautiful
items and video games so which produce I
mean in which part in the volution and
dynamics of the game and also time and
also price virtual art well so this our
two time series of from RPG game
Japanese RPG game so this the first one
are the sales actual sales of the game
and decision and the play time so for
casting those time series are obviously
crucial I mean sales because it's
definitely need it I mean in the sense
drop-down game developers can take
action to try to keep it balanced and
play time because if I mean we need to
- they need to - to have the resources
of the service ready if there is there's
a big for instance so I'm going to talk
about the auto regressive methods so
basically we we want to explain we want
to focus we want to explain and we want
to predict the future based on the path
of the series if we are going to talk
about auto regressive models of course
we have to start with both and Jenkins
work ARIMA models excuse me so you may
be wondering okay
I'm coming to a strange loop and they're
going to talk about the model that was
developed in the 70s
yes I mean because it's still one of
them of the methods that is most used
for any to solve almost also casting
problems these two good sorry together
with explanation there's nothing so is
yeah it's all but it still I mean even
as TM or other combination and our
networks for predicting time series for
I mean for doing two answers forecast
still our email is one of the best so
what how it does I mean some try to
decompose the serious with the past
information the auto regressive part
integrated the trends of the time series
and with the noise with the moving
average side also this thing we seen
with this is an oddity and of course you
can include covariates to to make those
predictions so here is the comparison of
the time series I saw you before of them
of the of the sales this is a forecast
in 30 days daily forecast and here we
here I compared dynamic regression which
is which includes animal models and some
covariates like vacation like different
game events or whether this is general
generalized additive mixed models this
is random boosting and this is deep
belief networks so we are still I mean
see that
ARIMA outperforms the rest and also when
we are evaluating forecasting systems we
always have to take into account about
the predictability and the minimum
training set we need to do accurate and
robust forecasts so great ability means
I mean I mean how the error is growing
as a long time goes by so what is the
forecast or Eason so we can see I mean
that in terms of credibility
ARIMA and and sorry and the generality
palliative mix models outperform the
rest and the same for the minimal
training so we need less amount of
information to start having distant
forecasts so I wanted to talk today
because I'm pretty optimistic and we
made several tests and it works pretty
well with the model deep R so this is a
model that it was developed by Amazon
researchers in Germany it was published
in ICML 2017 and it's a recursive
recurrent neural network auto regressive
recurrent neural network that is able to
learn from many time series maybe
hundreds of thousands you need but it's
about really to learn from the
historical data and it's able to do
predictions individual predictions for
every time serious so they use it for
this is what they used for the for doing
the prediction of the demand for every
product in Amazon website so the goal is
to model the conditional distribution of
the future of each time series given its
past and it's able to generalize from
similar stereos and you don't need to do
the manual work of explicit mark the
seasonality is it really learned
somatically from the from the rest of
the behavior of the time series and as
far as I mean it has been tested on our
side two dozen or fate so these are deep
are models has
the code in architecture so basically a
sequence to sequence that the output
from the encoder and covariates I mean
after the encoder produced the different
I mean the future steps in there in as
his mark in the horizontal so it's a
Auto regressive model because the the
observation at the last time step since
it is introduced as an input for the
lessor step and it's recurrent because
the previous output of the network is
feedback as an input in the next step so
the goal of the model of the DPR model
is to to model the conditional
distribution of every future of of every
time series so this is a schema of the
of the often of the neural network so
this is the training set and this is the
the prediction so what is what is using
is the I mean as I said before there the
target value the the truth of the
previous steps introduces an input for
the next step and the recurrent part is
because the output of the network is
feedback as a for the next step in the
in the network so this is for the
training set and for the for the
prediction for the forecast of course we
don't have the truth so then what is
used is just a sample of a full time
series that is marked by the by the
likelihood that a mean is it's a it's a
result of of the network output so to
select what is the the next time step I
mean the next input coming from the
previous step so also something more
interesting of of these method is that
the likelihood is a fixed distribution
which parameters are given by a function
from the level of the output but it
doesn't need to be Gaussian can be
choosing among different kind of
different types of distributions so we
compare for the time series that we
before with the PR and ARIMA and this is
just a particular I mean a particular
date but we observe that that they still
I mean for this particular sample DPR
works better if we compare with with
different dates still ARIMA performs
better in terms of accuracy but deeper
our results are very strong we have a
look for the minimum training that we
need still erima works whether but but
the cold start is
I mean it's particularly powerful for
DPR so so even even that the chorus is
lower is much easier to start with much
less women training data to start having
robust predictions also for the
simulation as I said before I mean this
is this is important for video game
industry be able and and also for for
almost every industry simulate the
effect of different promotional
marketing campaigns or in-game event how
it's going to influence sales how it's
going to influence playtime the
engagement of the players for instance
so in the case of ARIMA the relationship
between the other relationship between
the output on the inputs is linear we
can observe much easier how effect the
output of interest in this case sales
but in the case of DPR as this much more
complex model is much difficult to see
the direct influence of this what if as
scenarios there's a summary of what
means pros and cons of forecasting with
a riemann linear relationship easy to
then compose strongly negative but it
needs a lot of manual work from the
researchers can endure patterns across
there other times surgical have tons of
time series they're not going to learn
together it's very difficult to have
cold storage you'd really need a minimum
maybe depends on the output what data to
start having forecast and the feature
engineering is complex with the PR
the future engineers pretty simple as
almost work with rotator learning
process across the other time serious
cold stories was really nice and it's
able to to forecast even having many
times I mean different variability in
terms of magnitude among the different
time series on the other hand there is a
lack of control so at the end you're
making prediction for every single
product so some some of them are wrong
okay but is difficult to control and
it's costly to train okay
it's true that once you choose the
parameters everything is fine but take
some effort and then it's a black box I
also wanted to talk today about
recommendation systems as there are a
common challenge in both in both fields
here is the this is a recommendation
system that we built for for video game
industry and the goal for recommendation
system can be very diverse can be that
you go to for instance to an e-commerce
platform and you buy them you make a big
purchase it can be that you you want the
introducers make many but the small
purchases in this case what we wanted is
that to maximize retention so offered
recommend butyl items to two players in
order that they continue play in and
they are happy with with the game
they're having fun
so what we want is to to get player by
player individually the probability that
the probability that the of the nice
item they are going to purchase some
challenges is that to take into account
all play style and behavior information
and also the time both industries has
this this challenge in terms of
recommendation systems is not like maybe
with a series but it's not the big
challenge like in Netflix or most of the
pros in Amazon so in video games and
fashion the time matters I cannot give a
reward to a player a very big
beginner or because he's going to
completely break the game or I'm going
to give something very small so to a
whale I mean a player that is at the end
of the of the game because it's going to
be completely funded and it's going to
quit so the time I mean is is really
important for this this kind of
recommendation system and of course the
big data scalability so this is an
example of how we solve this problem so
we have many items too many so it was
very difficult to start doing
collaborative filtering or doing any
machine learning model so the first
thing we do is to reduce the
dimensionality with using a super
clustering and and then when we have the
clusters apply a machine learning model
able to predict every player which kind
of cluster is more likely that they
purchase nest once we know the cluster
that they will probably purchase nest we
need to come back to the item space
because at the end this recommendation
system is going to be connected to the
to the game so that the player needs to
receive something that so then we use a
collaborative filtering for every single
cluster to to come back to the to the to
the item space just some details about
how we did it so first is the similarity
matrix what we need to see what is the
distance and this was also very complex
between the between the items what is
similar what is not and also was taking
into account the time frame so we use
the grower distance to to come to to see
what items were similar and because he
was very flexible to work with
categorical numerical variables at all
so we'd use we could use the raw outputs
of this for the for the unsupervised
clustering method we do two hdvs can for
this because only needs one parameter to
be to be specified it's able to identify
outliers that don't create the classroom
when it is another year and it's able to
create clusters with different shapes
then we'd use and symbol learning at the
beginning we were reducing ostium but
extreme randomized States was working
brother so we changed so we use
extremely randomized wrists to assign to
predict what are the most likely
clusters players are going to super
taste nest among those items inside of
the clusters so student under my streets
arm has no mercy and the name says very
randomized race okay so they are able to
I mean normally decision trees works in
a way that that the variable that is
more correlated with the output of
interest is how it's going to start
growing the tree and the partition is
going to be also based on the
correlation so they're in the extreme in
their strength and on my street
everything is random okay so this is a
student efficient and is able to it's
also not it doesn't give us bias results
well afterwards we do reduce a
collaborative filtering to to come back
to to the to the item space and say
before so we use some implicit feedback
as a as a matrix factorization algorithm
also we use alternating least squares
and well we try not cover the filter for
every single cluster then we get the
discourse of the collaborative filtering
producer per cluster and then the the
deities with highest highest probability
is the one that is assigned to every to
every player also one of the talents is
the production part so been so we are
working with every single click players
perform in a game so this is the
information we have for every user since
they do in the game so be able to
understand for might and be able to
digest all this information and put it
in production was particularly
challenging so starting from the part of
the computation of probability per
player and cluster and the computation
of them
itis molarity and clustering of items so
all these bottlenecks were done
spark so and this is a summary of the of
our system of reporting production so we
were using Cassandra database we have
the front-end the web server the
heaviest computations were done in spark
and the lighter I mean the ones that we
can I mean just in in plain Java when
the when the model is I mean needs to be
properly paralyzed I mean we were
translating those models into spark but
just to conclude I mean of course there
were we were facing many to create
operational systems in industry almost I
think every word we're having many
technical challenges from a scalability
from data clearing the processing but
probably the most important challenge
and the motor vehicle one is the
communication so the communication
between that engineers and at a
scientist so as probably you might you
know you know I mean that engineers want
something extremely scalable in the
codes in the big data infrastructure and
that the scientists who wants the most
accurate model so having a compromise
between these two walls is probably key
for succeeding on this and just to
conclude I want to just remark one on
sentence of one of the the books I I
really like this I mean probably Yuri
Yudin really there is not a secret super
forecasting so in most cases a
statistical algorithms speed subjective
judgment I mean the handful of a studies
they don't they usually tie given that
algorithms are quick and chip
unlike subjective judgment at I support
using the algorithm the point is not
indisputable when you have a world
validated a statistical algorithm just
hit thank you
[Applause]